Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Leonardo Da Vinci is considered one of
the greatest poly mass to have ever lived.
He wasn't accomplished artists,
uh,
brilliant scientists and engineers
centuries ahead of his time and a man of
thought he saw farther and wider
than the people of his age and his
accomplishments and work still fascinate
us to this day and this video we're
going to examine some pieces of advice.
He left us throughout his life that
were central to his mindsets and his
achievement. Number 10
iron Russ. From this use,
water loses its purity and
stagnation even so to stagnation SAP,
the vigor of the mind. The Vinci had a
very powerful mind and like a muscle.
He knew the importance of exercising
it constantly. Basically daily,
the Vinci was learning and creating,
filling his notebooks with intricate
designs and studying intensely the world
around him.
His greatest intellectual achievements
were the products of hours upon hours
spent in study and work.
Davinci was also quoted as saying
the noblest pleasure is the joy of
understanding.
Number nine,
simplicity is the ultimate sophistication.
Davinci believes that the surest way to
understand something was to be able to
explain it simply and understand all
of the basic concepts behind something.
Having a very convoluted understanding
of something confuses not only the person
to whom you may be explaining something,
but may even confuse you at times.
Break it down to its essential oils.
Number eight,
anyone who conducts an argument by
appealing to authority is not using their
intelligence. They are using their
memory closely related to this.
Da Vinci was also quoted as saying,
where there is shouting.
There is no true knowledge. Davinci
questioned the legitimacy of everything.
Every power structure of the day.
He believed it was open
to his interpretation and
in renaissance Italy there
were plenty of authoritarian
power structures to question.
He believed that the
authority in dominance was not
sufficient for their word to
be followed, but someone said had to
make sense logically and objectively.
Number seven poor is the pupil
who does not surpass the master.
Davinci believed that it was not
only important for a student to learn
everything that they
could from the teacher,
but that a good student had the obligation
of taking that knowledge and going
further with it on their own.
The Vinci was such a student.
It is said that around the age of
20 when the Vinci's teacher growth,
you observed the work he had
done on an angel and a painting.
He has said to a put down his brush and
declared that he would never paint again.
Davinci had surpassed him.
Number six I have been impressed
with the urgency of doing.
Knowing is not enough. We must apply.
Being willing is not enough. We must do.
The Vinci was the sort of person who has
spent hours and hours and contemplation,
exploration and design,
but also learn very well the importance
of implementing his ideas and applying
his knowledge in the real world.
Though his notebooks filled with
designs and theories are amazing.
Some of the Vinci's greatest moments
we're in utilizing that knowledge.
Number five.
It had long since come to my attention
that people of accomplishment rarely sat
back and let things happen to them.
They went out and happened to things.
This is somewhat related to the thinking
behind Number Six da Vinci had a desire
to be an accomplished in the and in fact,
he did accomplish many things in life
and worked for and with many other great
individuals of renaissance,
Italy and fields like arc politics
and even a little bit of war.
But these opportunities
didn't just come to him.
He went out and sought after
them vigorously. Number four,
how many emperors and how many princess
have lived and died and no record of
them remains yet they only
sought to gain to minions,
enriches that their
fame may be everlasting.
Davinci want it to be
an accomplished person,
but he was not after what he considered
to be superficial fame and material
accomplishment. He valued
greatly achievements in
science, philosophy and art,
things that he believed would
better himself and humanity.
It was in his contributions and these
fields that he would have a lasting effect
on humanity and that was more important
than any fame he could acquire.
Number three, you can have no dominion
greater or less than that of yourself.
Davinci believes that the greatest
battles were waged over one's internal
weaknesses and that the greatest
victory is where those over them.
He was not a military or political leader.
He was a very startling individual and
his life was spent on improving himself
as much as possible.
Number two,
I have offended God and mankind because
my work did not reach the quality it
should have.
This is not so much a piece of advice
as it is a quote which represents how to
Vinci thought. Davinci was very hard
on himself as we said in number three.
He was constantly seeking to better
himself and to improve on everything he
could. Being satisfied with
yourself can lead to stagnation,
which Inda Vinci's mind is a bad thing.
His mind was always going further.
He may have been a bit too hard on
himself though and somewhat sadly.
Those were actually his last words.
However,
don't be too sad because the
Vinci also said, number one,
as a well-spent day brings happy sleep.
So well spent.
Life brings happy death in many aspects
we can See da Vinci was actually
satisfied with many parts of his life.
He spoke these words in old age believing
he had done well and live life very
well and fully. That's isn't
an inevitability for all of us,
but whatever death is,
Davinci believe that it won't be quite
so bad if it has been proceeded by a rich
and fulfilling life,
and in fact,
living such a life is all
we can do in the face of it.
There is of course more
to learn from the Vinci,
but these were just
some of his best quotes.
Let me know what you think of
them in the comment section below.
And for more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.